let's begin with these guys over here
now they're exact values and if you have
a look this is cannon fodder for your
calculator okay
yet you actually can work out for
instance K 345 I could say that that's
10 of 180 degrees plus 45 degrees and so
that's 10 of 45 why is that by the way
why is that equal to that comes up that
brings the period of 10 plus 6 thank you
so every imagine adriennes you're
getting the same value over and over
again and you know what Tansley 5 is is
1 now it's good to be able to do that
however if you're in attention just
click that calculator out there's no
reason why not - ok simplex you have to
look up books with this kind of thing
that's why you have a calculator you can
do that for all these these are fine
these will come out pretty easily your
calculator will spit out a we value so
this right area minus 0.57 I kind of
what it is but if you square that it
will give you a heart what exact so yes
what if you don't rationalize every
marker well use all this versus our vs.
it is that we thank you
this is actually despite the fact that
it's not a rational denominator this is
what you'll find is the most common way
to say it so I'm quite happy with that
if you wrote the about me it's still the
same number but opposite ok do you want
to ridge three four o'clock 60 I don't
have a cot thick pork otech button on
your calculator but all you have to do
is input one 110 60 and then there's
your other exact values okay are you
happy with that
get a negative they do matter okay now
just coming down this guy so hello look
now you go what down let me point out
for you because so often is before and I
just kind of I let it go for a little
while
hotter squared we haven't looked at the
graph of the squares of the
trigonometric function so let me pick an
opportunity to show you okay now if you
go and take in cos x and slap brackets
around the whole thing and square it
this is what you get okay
now just ignore the fact that my answers
here let me see if i just put in x
equals two pi
oh no you're gonna have to do wrong oh
yes there we go there it is
okay so let me put this right next to
the regular codex graph and see if I can
explain roughly what's going on their
noses
okay so total rest their content going
root down like that as you would expect
it to okay so we can do cos x and then
you square the whole thing what we'd
like is cos square then you can this
mean things waves up and down more than
the previous function can you see why
how many batteries summer what if you
just go from north tonight well tonight
wait look at this blue graph that's the
one we actually want it also goes from 1
to 0 that should surprise you because 1
squared is 1 and 0 squared is 0 okay but
then what happens from 97 81 W on yeah
really
okay for starters the entire blue graph
is above the axes you notice that okay
because you're taking some number and
you square it into their portable
poverty very similar absolute values but
let's in look the shape actually changes
a little bit so you get you get the
extra
it looks just like for this part here
not look like a college function except
though it's squashed into that little
space so you get this and then you get
another hole copy so what you're getting
now is of your solving back to the
original question when is it equal to
3/4 so why y equals 3 get rid of this
guy okay
so you can see there's a 1 2 3 4
siliceous you're supposed to get now
came back to the work is how do I get
for solutions well when you take the
square root of both sides over here you
get plus or minus another way to see it
is which I clued you into this morning
is that that line there I could write it
like this I know it probably doesn't
look like much of an improvement but it
might help you see actually you can't
write this thing as differences whereas
can you not there's a minus B and there
is the a plus B do you agree
does that make sense to see 3/4 is just
route 302 well so your exact values can
be Satan breeze and it actually makes it
even easier since you've got a plus and
you've got - and if you're going to
worry about with Korky trick you're in
all the question ok you're going to be a
cute angle
you've got the obtuse one there it is
180 minus 30 and then you've got the two
reflex angles 180 + 30 + 360 minus 30
so make a port solution